all right nfc west some great great
teams at one point last year we thought
they'd put three teams in the playoffs
they ultimately got two the seahawks and
the rams let's spin it ahead to 2021 and
we're gonna do this on a scale of one to
ten speed round style scale of 1 to 10
the impact of kyler murray
as a potential free agent recruiter for
the cardinals
it's up there for sure like i don't know
if it's as high as you know the mahomes
the brady
you know some of the those guys but
i'm gonna put it at about
i'm gonna say a seven
seven i'm seven eight ish but i'll go
with seven and i think you know i also
just
i look at them and go
they could use i think another big time
receiver another more if you're gonna
play that way they need more firepower
they want to open the field up do that
not that they need to go out and spend
20 million dollars on a receiver but
another guy who's opposite of deandre
hopkins where you go wait he's one on
one he's gonna beat your guy and you're
in trouble you better watch out for that
but i'll say seven what about you
i'm gonna say six if they had made it to
the playoffs i'd feel more strongly
about it there's gonna be so many other
teams out there that i think are gonna
attract the guys who get cut or who
become free agents and don't have other
teams throwing a bunch of money at them
so they're going to take one-year deals
i think we're going to see a lot of
one-year deals and you're going to have
guys gravitate toward the teams that are
the clear contenders the cardinals are
in i think a fairly narrow band of i
don't know which side of the line
they're on we've got the teams that we
know are contenders the teams that we
are confident aren't and then there's
maybe a few where it's like it could go
either way you're right right and i
agree and i don't think we saw we've
seen enough from the cardinals
that kyle murray in and of himself is
going to be able to recruit a bunch of
guys to join the team and i don't think
it's in his nature to be kind of vocal
and constantly texting someone and and
pushing that that's just not who he is
that's not who he is
and that that's fine we all have to be
true to who we are he's true to who he
is and i don't think he's the kind of
guy that's gonna constantly pester
someone come join us come join us come
join us come join us come join us larry
fitzgerald what's the impact to the
cardinals if fitzgerald retires a scale
of one to ten
like
a four or five and i don't mean that to
be disrespectful to larry fitzgerald
i don't i mean again he's a first ballot
hall of famer uh he's awesome i think
the main impact of him on the team is
just leadership work ethic things he
does
like from that aspect but as far as just
pure
ability and playmaking and all those
type of things
you know i don't look at that if he's
not there as a huge loss to their
football team yes he does some things he
still run blocks well and does a lot of
things that way but i don't think it's a
make or break thing for their offense
and listen i don't like saying that
because i really like larry fitzgerald
well but that's why they would need
another receiver because i think we're
all operating under the assumption he's
going to retire right i don't think he's
ever taken it this long
into his
offseason to say he's coming back right
and he's also due to become a free agent
and i remember there was a time when i
thought he was going to end up in
minnesota because he was a ball boy for
the vikings back in 98 when chris carter
and randy moss and jake reed were there
and his father larry fitzgerald senior
sports writer in the minnesota area has
said in the past now it's been a while
since he last said it that he believes
larry will end up with the vikings at
some point at this point though i i
think he's he's arizona or no one
uh and uh he's in he's another guy who
can do anything he wants
post football and he'll be successful at
it whether it's broadcasting i've
thought at times maybe he'll get into
politics i think he could have a real
impact there but uh he he he's taking
his time
and he's entitled to that but the longer
he takes just like drew bree well with
drew brees the longer he takes the more
we think he's coming back yeah with
larry fitzgerald the longer he takes the
more we think he's going to retire uh
and i think four or five is the right
range as well if he retires because he's
not an integral part of that offense
anymore impact of the rams losing
brandon staley their defensive
coordinator who's now the head coach of
the same stadium chargers one to ten
what's the impact i i mean it's low to
me
you know and that's not anything against
brandon staley but i'm going to say
you know one or two
because i i just think that highly of
raheem morris i know i think brandon
staley is awesome he's definitely one of
the best defensive minds in the game i
think raheem morris is like damn good
too he's right up there so i think what
he'll be you know it will look a little
different like we talked about earlier
but i don't think it's going to be like
oh man wow you know this scheme just
doesn't fit their team and it's not
sound and it doesn't make sense no way
no way raheem is the real deal holyfield
for sure so i don't think it's a huge
blow to them i think they they got a you
know a gift in getting him as defensive
coordinator
i still think it's more than one to lose
staley the the rave reviews he got just
the mere fact that the continuity factor
isn't there i think it's a four or a
five okay
just because you you didn't hire brandon
staler with the idea you'd be replacing
him after one year you wanted him to be
there for a while just the disruption
that comes from new defensive
coordinator but i agree with you raheem
morris could do a great job and it's
easy to do a great job when you've got
aaron donald and jalen ramsey on that
defense impact of the 49ers losing their
defensive coordinator robert saula to
the jets one to ten well this is to me a
little bit uh of a a greater one here
i'm gonna go with like a seven you know
i just i don't know but i don't know
d'amico ryan's i haven't seen him
you know be defensive coordinator yet i
got a lot of evidence on rahim morris
and a lot of evidence just from this
past year ago damn he did some awesome
things with like not that talented of a
defense there in atlanta when he took
over you know salah special his energy
his leadership and even you know i'm you
know me i don't i don't always love that
seattle scheme
but he threw enough little curve balls
in there
to make it you know
not as predictable as maybe some other
people who running that or running that
scheme uh but i just amiko ryan's
unproven at this point i i i don't doubt
that he can be a really damn good coach
and he's been around football but uh he
has not done it so that that's to me
where i'll go with like a seven here
now
raheem morris has a lot more coaching
experience than demiko ryan's you know
morris was not a defensive coordinator
in the nfl for the first time until last
year i i know i know but he was
acting like a defensive coordinator when
i was with him in tampa bay he was
phenomenal he really was and the people
he learned from and was around whether
it's monty kiffin rod marinelli mike
tomlin joe berry who's the new defensive
coordinator up in green bay i mean they
were all like defensive coordinators
they were amazing so i know it doesn't
it doesn't uh i didn't really think
about that aspect of it but it doesn't
affect my decision either way
one thing i'd never known and if i did
i'd forgotten it during his time with
the buccaneers he left for a year to be
the defensive coordinator at kansas
state right then was back and then went
back following season right yeah right
and i think that's strange did that lead
to them
taking the quarterback you know uh out
of kansas state freeman oh i can't
remember josh freeman yeah i think
or was it 2009 that was 2009. that was
raheem's first year as head coach 2009
that was the year they drafted josh
freeman who who did well until greg
ciano became the coach and uh then he
was he was done all right one more
impact of the seahawks changing
offensive coordinators setting aside the
russell wilson factor just shane waldron
in for brian schottenheimer one to ten
well i i certainly think it's an
improvement i do um schottenheimer
there's things i like but waldron's to
be able to bring
different aspects and angles to this
offense that they have not have so uh
impact there again i'm not going to go
oh it's a 10 it's going to be so awesome
but i'll i'll go with the cop out number
seven again
i'll agree with you the question is will
waldron have the cajones yeah to become
the kahuna
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports